[Music]
joe biden doesn't appear in public very
often too scary he doesn't want to get
the ronan but when he does and once he
starts talking it's hard to slow that
man down can't stop him his press
conference went on for two hours
and of course it wasn't all about covid
it wasn't about anything that actually
mattered no questions on crime or
immigration murder rates up dramatically
the southern borders opened millions of
foreign nationals whose names we don't
know are streaming in
but don't ask and nobody did but biden
did have the chance and certainly had
the time to make a lot of strange claims
about his first year in office
some of it was just very very strange
here's a selection
in fact my plan cuts the deficit and it
boosts the economy by getting more
people into the workforce and so i don't
think i've over promised at all and i'm
gonna stay on this track very few
schools are closing
over 95
are still open no matter how hard they
make it for minorities to vote
i think you're going to see them willing
to stand in line
and and defy the attempt to keep them
from being able to vote let me get
something straight here
how long are you guys ready to go you
want to go for another hour two putin
has a you know has uh a stark choice uh
he either de-escalation or diplomacy a
confrontation of the consequences i'm
not so sure he
has certain what he's going to do my
guess is he will move in
he has to do something i think report
cards can look pretty good if that's
where we're at
made a kind of a quick back of the
envelope list here my plan cuts the
deficit by spending trillions more
that'll work
very few schools are closed just happens
to be your kids schools and your sisters
kids schools and the schools of everyone
you know
but most schools are not close very few
in fact
no matter how hard they try to make it
for minorities to vote and that's the
one that sticks out being completely
false but also utterly divisive some
percentage of people are going to
believe that
to think that your government is making
it harder for you to exercise your
franchise because your skin color if you
wanted to increase hatred and division
that's exactly what you'd say and that's
what he said